faites vos recherches les réseaux
sociaux aurait un côté obscur et il
pourrait créer une dépendance
georges et rosalie le savent trop bien
en fait j'ai beaucoup d'application
pourraient diminuer autant d'écrins et
j'étais accro mais là j'ai désactivé
tout mais notification de genzyme
it's been one le documentaire derrière
nos écrans de fumée de netflix se penche
sur la part d'ombré des réseaux sociaux
à l'aide de témoignages d'anciens
employés et plus ont deux géants comme
google
instagram et facebook tous affirment que
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
créer une dépendance comme la drogue
c'est vrai que ces systèmes étaient
essentielles sont entraînés à prédire
nos réactions puisqu'elle qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous montrer pour que vous
passiez plus de temps devant l'écran
donc il ya une vérité sous jacente
seulement le contrôle que ces systèmes
laon sur nous et pas du tout à l'échelle
qui est ce qui est montré le
documentaire va assez loin allant même
jusqu'à dire que les réseaux sociaux
infligerait un lavage de cerveau à
certains utilisateurs en manipulant
leurs pensées à leur insu les outils
technologiques avec la publicité les
réseaux sociaux tire parti d'un aux
biens cognitifs de nos faiblesses
psychologiques finalement pour nous
influencer et ça c'est quelque chose
dont on doit se préoccuper mais c'est
chaque maire avec leurs théories du
complot leurs fausses nouvelles et leur
lot de trolls les réseaux sociaux
devenus en contrôle aurais tu un impact
majeur sur notre niveau d'anxiété
depuis leur arrivée son téléphone
portable il y a dix ans absolument en
fait il ya beaucoup de données
même au québec qui montrent que le taux
de dépression le taux d'anxiété
le taux de d'antidépresseurs le taux de
danse iolite etc et même de
psychostimulants pour le tdah
tous ces indicateurs la même le taux
d'hospitalisation pour des idées
suicidaires ils ont tous augmenté depuis
dix ans la solution passe nécessairement
par l'éducation et la sensibilisation à
la maison et dans les écoles et même si
le documentaire de netflix trace un
portrait plutôt sombre
keven lacombe
bien sûr les réseaux sociaux n'ont pas
que du mauvais ils peuvent être
divertissant rassembleur informatif et
porteur de changement tout dépend bien
sûr de l'utilisation que l'on en fait
ici wifi depuis mai radio-canada mourir